Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同发起的“追求经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am guiding you through two important steps that can help you think about weathering the storm on your journey
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会直接赢取Lisa提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。在今天的《有抱负的心理学家》播客中，我将引导你完成两个重要的步骤，帮助你思考如何在旅途中应对风暴，
to becoming whatever type of aspiring psychologist you fancy being. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Here we are with another episode from the Marianne's Summer Soundbite series, which are going to be slightly shorter episodes than the standard episodes to help you to be able to continue engaging with your goals for learning and development in psychology over this summer period, when you might be a little bit busier. Don't worry, this isn't a permanent change to the format and the usual longer and guest episodes will be around over the summer and in the autumn again too.
无论你想成为哪种类型的心理学家。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这就是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是临床心理学家Marianne Trent博士。这是“Marianne夏季短片”系列的又一集，这些节目比标准集稍短，旨在帮助你在夏季这个可能比较忙碌的时期，继续保持对心理学学习和发展的追求。别担心，这并不是格式的永久改变，夏季过后，秋季依然会有常规的较长集数和嘉宾访谈。
Another series that you might well know and love is the free Compassionate Q&A series. Don't worry, that one is back for the 2023 season too. Here's all the details you need to know. So as you can see on your screen we have the first of those coming up on Monday the 4th of September 2023 and that starts at 6pm. A replay will of course be available too and the best place to find the replay is Dr. Marianne Trent on YouTube. The second of the sessions is Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023 also at 6 p.m. Again a replay is available. And the third and final session to support application season for the Declined Cyber also EdCycle is also a similar time of year
你可能熟悉并喜爱的另一个系列是免费的“同理心问答”（Compassionate Q&A）系列。别担心，它也会在2023年回归。以下是你需要了解的所有细节。正如你在屏幕上看到的，第一场活动将于2023年9月4日星期一晚上6点开始。当然也会提供回放，找到回放的最佳地点是YouTube上的Dr. Marianne Trent频道。第二场会议是2023年10月3日星期二，同样在晚上6点。同样提供回放。第三场也是最后一场会议，旨在支持申请季，时间也在一年中的相似时段，
is going to be Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm. So don't wait, don't delay, connect with me on socials now so that you can dive right in when the time comes. On LinkedIn I am Dr Marianne Trent, come and connect or follow. On Twitter I'm also Dr Marianne Trent, although on Twitter I can't see your comments because StreamYard and Twitter don't integrate properly, but if you want to just watch from Twitter, you absolutely can. On YouTube, I am Dr. Marianne Trent. My Facebook page is also Dr. Marianne Trent. And last but of course not the least, come and join my free Facebook community group which is called the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent. I do always endeavour to get live on
将于2023年11月7日星期二晚上6点举行。所以不要等待，不要拖延，现在就关注我的社交媒体，这样当时间到来时，你就可以直接参与了。在LinkedIn上，我是Dr. Marianne Trent，欢迎连接或关注。在Twitter上，我也是Dr. Marianne Trent，虽然在Twitter上我无法看到你的评论，因为StreamYard和Twitter的集成不够完善，但如果你只是想从Twitter观看，完全没问题。在YouTube上，我是Dr. Marianne Trent。我的Facebook页面也是Dr. Marianne Trent。最后但同样重要的是，欢迎加入我的免费Facebook社区群组，名为“Dr. Marianne Trent的有抱负的心理学家社区”。我总是努力进行直播，
Instagram as well but it's not quite so interactive because it means I have to get my phone rigged up behind my webcam. It's a little bit rustic but you absolutely should be able to catch it there too. And on Instagram and on Threads I am Dr. Marianne Trent. So let's not wish the summer away, let's make it a really mindful and enjoyable one. So let's take a look at another of Marianne's Summer Soundbites. You, my dear, have a unique perspective to offer you are the product of your own upbringing of those you've met those who spent time those you've been around those you've learned from those you've been in staff teams with those you have
在Instagram上也是如此，但互动性没那么强，因为这意味着我必须把手机架在网络摄像头后面。虽然有点简陋，但你绝对可以在那里看到直播。在Instagram和Threads上，我都是Dr. Marianne Trent。所以，让我们不要虚度夏天，让我们过一个真正用心且愉快的夏天。现在，让我们来看看“Marianne夏季短片”的另一集。亲爱的，你拥有独特的视角，你是你自身成长经历的产物，是你所遇见的人、共度时光的人、你身边的人、你向其学习的人、你曾共事的团队成员、你曾
been in school cohorts with you are the product of your experiences and all of those things have given you a unique perspective or maybe you've always felt a little bit like a black sheep in your collective and you've always felt like you think about things in a slightly different way but whatever position you find yourself to be in you are unique and you are special and I believe you have something rich and rewarding to be able to offer your clients maybe even shape building growth services interventions research and important things that are going to make a real difference to people's lives around the country around the UK
在学校里共处的同学的产物。你是你经历的结晶，所有这些都赋予了你独特的视角。或者，也许你一直觉得自己在这个集体中有点像“害群之马”，总是觉得自己的思考方式与众不同。但无论你处于什么位置，你都是独特的，你是特别的。我相信你拥有丰富且有价值的东西，可以提供给你的客户，甚至可能塑造和建立成长服务、干预措施、研究以及那些将对全国、英国乃至
and the world for that matter and that all comes from you that comes from your commitment and your determination and the unique way that you see the world and the problems that you will navigate and how you come up with ideas to get around them to overcome them makes me think about the famous book going on a bear hunt no we can't go over it we can't go under it we can't go under it. We can't go around it. We have to go through it. And, you know, you will find your own ways to get over, round, down, under the problems. Or, you know, to have a real errorless learning approach where you eradicate the problem cropping up in the first place. You have the opportunity to bring fresh perspectives and
全世界人们的生活产生真正影响的重要事物。这一切都源于你，源于你的承诺、你的决心，以及你看待世界和处理问题的方式。你如何想出办法来绕过它们、克服它们，让我想起了那本著名的书《猎熊记》——不，我们不能越过它，我们不能从它下面穿过，我们不能绕过它。我们必须穿过它。你知道，你会找到自己的方法来克服、绕过、解决问题。或者，你知道，采取一种真正的“无错误学习”方法，从源头上消除问题的出现。你有机会带来新的视角和
fresh insight and fresh, you know, determination and enthusiasm to the career, to the field. And I know when I was in my second year of training, my supervisor, who rarely managed to break both of her arms. At the same time, I recently broke one of my arms. So sending lots of love to you. She said to me during a supervision session, just how much she had enjoyed supervising assistants and trainees, because she felt that she gained and learned so much from them, the way that they saw the world and the things that excited and delighted them and, you know, drove them, their passions, the things they were interested in, the research they've done and the clinical areas and populations they've previously worked with.
新的见解，以及新的决心和热情投入到这个职业和领域中。我记得我在培训的第二年，我的主管——她很少能同时摔断两只胳膊，而我最近摔断了一只胳膊，所以向你发送很多爱——她在督导期间对我说，她非常喜欢督导助理和实习生，因为她觉得她从他们身上学到了很多，他们看待世界的方式，让他们兴奋和高兴的事情，以及驱动他们的动力、他们的热情、他们感兴趣的事物、他们所做的研究，以及他们之前工作过的临床领域和人群。
So, yeah, don't forget to really consider yourself as unique. Don't necessarily feel like just because, you know, you're not in agreement with someone else in the team or perhaps even your supervisor that you're wrong or that you need to squish that in some way. So sometimes we need to be able to play the game. But of course, if you've got concerns about anything, then you need to raise those in the appropriate way. But you know, it's okay to explore the way you see the world in supervision and to think about cultivating your own research and clinical interests. Let's take a quick break and I'll be back along with the next of our learning points. Thank you. Welcome back. So the second of today's points for consideration is thinking about learning as a continuous journey. It's a lifelong journey as
所以，是的，别忘了真正把自己视为独特的个体。不要仅仅因为你与团队中的其他人，甚至你的主管意见不一致，就觉得你是错的，或者觉得你需要以某种方式压抑自己。有时候我们需要学会玩转职场游戏。但当然，如果你对任何事情有疑虑，你需要以适当的方式提出来。但你知道，在督导中探索你看待世界的方式，并思考培养自己的研究和临床兴趣是没问题的。让我们休息一下，稍后我会回来分享下一个学习要点。谢谢。欢迎回来。所以今天第二个需要考虑的要点是，将学习视为一个持续的旅程。这也是一个终身的旅程，
well. So it might feel that you, you know, the time is not quite right for you at the moment. So even among the people that I did my undergraduate psychology degree with in the late 90s and early 2000s, there's recently been people who have started to think that maybe a career in professional psychology might be for them and so it's never too late as you might well remember from our recent podcast episodes with Fiona and with Mark when it's your time and you're ready for the next step you can always climb back on board and the rich way that you will have learned about life and clients and how to tackle and overcome difficulties and also how to better engage service users from your time doing different
所以你可能会觉得，现在时机还不成熟。即使在我90年代末和2000年代初读心理学本科时认识的人中，最近也有人开始认为心理学职业可能适合他们。所以永远不会太晚，正如你可能还记得我们最近与Fiona和Mark的播客节目中所提到的，当你的时机到了，准备好迈出下一步时，你随时可以重新加入。你在从事不同职业追求期间所学到的关于生活、客户、如何应对和克服困难，以及如何更好地吸引服务对象的丰富经验，
career pursuits is likely to be invaluable, not just to the clients you work with, but also to your peers who end up being in your cohort and ultimately in your teams. Stay curious, you know, commit yourself to expanding your knowledge and your skills. If a training opportunity quats up, ask if you can do it. If there might even be a training budget in your department, how you could put in a bid or a request to be able to fulfill some of your learning objectives. And this is where your yearly appraisal, if you have one, can be really useful too. So I hope you've found today's episode of Marianne's Summer Sandbites useful. If you like the kind of things that I've got to offer, do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership.
不仅对你合作的客户来说是无价的，对最终与你同届、并最终进入你团队的同僚来说也是如此。保持好奇心，致力于扩展你的知识和技能。如果有培训机会出现，问问你是否可以参加。如果你的部门甚至有培训预算，你可以考虑如何提交申请或请求，以实现你的一些学习目标。这就是你的年度评估（如果有的话）非常有用的地方。希望你觉得今天的“Marianne夏季短片”很有用。如果你喜欢我所提供的内容，请查看“有抱负的心理学家”会员计划。
I hope you're being kind to yourself. Hope you're having a really lovely summer. I will look forward to catching up with you for the next episode of the aspiring psychologist podcast which is around for Monday 6am thank you so much for being part of my world and be kind to yourself if you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified
希望你善待自己。希望你度过一个非常愉快的夏天。我期待在下一集《有抱负的心理学家》播客中与你相见，节目将于周一早上6点发布。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请善待自己。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这就是《有抱负的心理学家》播客，我是Marianne Trent博士。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。